[Musique]
bonjour à tous grand sourire
l'uia marc est arrivée comme une petite
souris dans ce studio pendant le journal
de céline ainsi que charles chargé du
mal à dire que c'est une petite pensée
gros non plus 6h08 le physique à part
sur des bases solides
c'est très compliqué pour délibérer
expliqua ce qui ne vous voit pas que
pour parler vous avez mis votre masque
sur le menton du coup cette terre sur
les lacie qui rabat les oreilles et je
ne vous cache pas dans les sept nains
vous dans 3 116 communes d'ariège il est
autorisé depuis le 15 avril de se
promener dans les rues sans match sauf
durant les marchés et aux abords des
établissements scolaires tout est légal
et officiel
j'ai la chance d'être à saverdun et
qu'on n'est pas oubliée zoommed parce
que c'est le préfet qui l'a décidé même
si le nombre de nouveaux cas positifs
est en baisse
la situation reste très préoccupante en
france hier le cap des 6000 malades de
lakovic 19 hospitalisés en réanimation a
été à nouveau franchi pour la première
fois depuis la première vague de
l'épidémie
cette maladie tue les gens qui sont le
fragile les voyages naturel nettoyage
naturel pardonnez moi mais je referme et
absolument elle voudrait dire que donc
est des gens c'est naturel on s'en fiche
il en est destiné à l'euro je pense que
la balade se termine par la mort quoi
qu'on fasse
c est dire que c'est ça la réalité c'est
à dire ça si tu étais ministre de la
santé premier ministre ou président tu
ferais quoi tu continuerait tu
maintiendrait le confinement non non
parce que la canche et qu'il coache
l'impression que tu es le premier
ministre à pinochet quoi je veux dire à
un moment donné ça fait neuf ans qu'on
est en couvre feu ça sent le gâteau le
régime de pinochet quoi et les gens
peuvent plus quoi franchement chaque
fois que je viens ici j'ai affaire à un
con comme vous je vais vous dire une
chose chaque fois je j'ai un bon qu'au
bout et je vais vous dire une chose je
vais le répéter c'est pas très très gai
et ce n'est pas très raide raffiné mais
je vous rappelle pierre desproges
il y parlait à un conte ou essayer de le
convaincre c'est comme se masturber avec
une râpe à fromage beaucoup de
souffrance pour peu de résultats la
baronne se laisse embrasser et saisi
l'entrecuisse de morrow il attire alors
vers lui et commence à défaire ce à rome
au rythme de son souffle a le temps sage
ajoute le nez nuit elle se plante devant
lui arrache la redingote de moreau son
gilet sa chemise découvrant alors un
torse large et vigoureux ok ok ok pas et
on 3,8
comment je vais expliquer son sexe long
et large a pris la dimension de son
désir c'est pas mal écrit madame la
baronne ne peut empêcher un soupir
admiratif à vendre sans pareil du sexe
d'une bouche largement ouverte
voyez ça fait 10 dinars est là elle l'a
lu dix fois bonjour mais s'il faut
arrêter toutes ces émissions
oui parce qu'elles rendent compte ah oui
vraiment ouais bah c'est cette
catastrophe pour vous saisissez déverser
des enfants mon grand désespoir ils ont
entre 12 et 17 ans en regardant
désespoir ils regardent comme d'ailleurs
à près de la moitié de nos jeunes alors
moi j'ai vu j'ai accepté de venir
débattre pas parce que la télé réalité
m'intéresse mais parce que c'est un
phénomène qui touche des millions de nos
jeunes
[Musique]
alain lieury chercheur à l'université de
rennes a fait une étude très sérieuse
sur 27 mille collégiens en classe de 3e
qui montre que ceux qui suivent la télé
réalité tous les soirs eh bien ils ont
une baisse de leur niveau en
mathématiques de 11 % et une baisse de
l'essence général de 16% mais s'accroît
pourquoi parce que les émissions de télé
réalité sont extrêmement pauvres en
vocabulaire
comprenez bien on fait du genre je
cherche un homme sans te dire comment le
faire par exemple on attendait dans
[Musique]
presque chaque fois on est mal barrés un
temps d'opérer normalement on utilise à
peu près 1000 mots en parlant la télé
réalité les tennis 6 ans donc la télé
réalité c'est vraiment le virus qui rend
con et quand c'est des jeunes
effectivement c'est très très
problématique qu'on a dit ça doit aussi
dense sur charlie hebdo
ah ben on bouge parfois les sièges sont
parfois injectables
[Musique]
à
je me sens propulsé d'un coup à une
vitesse mais jamais vu un truc pareil
je m'attendais à une sensation forte
mais peut-être pas aussi forte
alors regarde là le rouge c'est celui
qui le dira at sur le mort et caisses
car en dessous du nord le sud ouest
ils sont devenus la risée du web sur un
malentendu
ces automobilistes américains de l'état
du kentucky n'ont pas l'air de savoir
comment fonctionne un rond point
beaucoup se mettre carrément a roulé à
contresens al'approche de ce tout
nouveau giratoire
seulement voilà cette vidéo partagée par
de nombreux internautes sans aucun
contexte a été diffusé à l'origine par
les services de la voirie eux mêmes
comme un exemple de ce qu'il ne faut pas
faire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
lui non plus ne bouge plus
[Musique]
autant la fraise a le goût de la fraise
autant la vie a le goût du bonheur
non mais laissez pour moi elle est pour
moi ça me parler pour me former
il m'a invitée dans ton rêve ma chérie
tu arrives ici
c
l'arrêt du tout